If you ain't got tatted by Cartoon,
you ain't got no tat.
If you ain't get shot by Estevan,
you got a weak photographer.
Yo, kick it off, dog.
Hip-hop culture owes so much
to Toons and Estevan.
Cartoon, baby.
-My boy, Cartoon.
-Cartoon.
Everything Cartoon did,
-Estevan was there.
-Capturing the whole culture.
-Lowrider culture. Tattoo culture.
-Everything, man.
I'm a photographer and director,
raised in LA.
Hip hop was new.
I'm on tour with the Beastie Boys,
No Doubt,
The Fugees, Limp Bizkit...
And I'm the only one there with a camera.
I had to draw every day.
At the time, in the '80s, it was all about
"Where do you fit in in hip hop?"
He was an awesome graffiti writer.
I remember, like, his first
tattoos, it was like, "Oh, it's over."
Cartoon gave Eminem
one of his first tattoos.
I was documenting
Cartoon tattooing
the biggest artists in the world
at that time.
It is a buddy comedy.
And the more we hung out,
the more we just started building on ideas
of things that we could do to make money
that weren't illegal.
We looked at each other and we were like,
"We need to go to the next level, man."
And they grew that empire.
Soul Assassin Studios.
Sh** just happened.
These dudes are like cholo da Vincis.
They've been unstoppable
ever since.
They paved the way
for a lot of people.
Now you have a new wave
of Chicano artists
that can focus on Chicano pride.
They are LA.